[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben heute habe ich mal auf
eure Kommentare gehört weil ihr meintet
Kiki zeig uns doch mal eine Torte jetzt
für die anstehenden Weihnachtsfeiertage
und ich habe mir gedacht eine wofür ihr
nicht so das Equipment braucht eine die
einfach ist und trotzdem richtig cool
aussieht und entstanden ist eine hübsche
tannenbaumtorte mit rosa deek und Schnee
oben drüber also unbedingt dran bleiben
ich zeig euch nämlich jetzt wie einfach
das funktioniert so wenn ihr euch jetzt
gefragt habt ob i irgendwie eine
bestimmte tannenbaumform braucht kann
ich euch nur sagen brauchen wir nicht
wir machen un ganz einfach wir backen
jetzt einfach ein Blechkuchen und dann
schneiden wir uns Kreise aus also ihr
braucht da nichts spezielles für und
alle Zutaten bekommt ihr auch ganz easy
peasy bei Kaufland ich werde jetzt hier
erstmal die Eier in meine Schüssel
geben so und dann gehen wir auch schon
Zucker mit dazu und schlagen das so 2 D
Minuten lang dick
[Musik]
cremig so sieht die Masse aus Wahnsinn
ne man wird schon denken das ist ein
fertiger Teig aber es sind eigentlich
nur zwei Zutaten ich gebe jetzt für den
Geschmack noch Vanilleextrakt mit dazu
ich einen schönen vanilleboden erhalte
und auch noch mal eine ordentliche
Messerspitze Salz die hebt noch mal den
süßen Geschmack das Rü ich jetzt noch
nicht unter denn ich gebe jetzt auch
schon Sonnenblumenöl mit dazu ihr könnt
auch Rapsöl nehmen Hauptsache irgendein
neutrales Öl Olivenöl würde da jetzt
nicht so gut zupassen wobei ich mal
einen süßen Kuchen mit Olivenöl in
Griechenland gebacken habe das hat echt
gut geschmeckt aber in dem Fall brauchen
wir das nicht jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
unterrühren also wirklich nur ein paar
Sekunden und dann Siebe ich alle trocken
Zutaten mit dazu und rühre das auch noch
mal ganz langsam unter und ganz wichtig
nur so lange wie notwendig und nicht
[Musik]
überrühren
den Teig habe ich auch noch eingefärbt
in bordoro das ist natürlich euch
überlassen ich fand es einfach
persönlich sehr sehr hübsch und dann
eingefüllt in mein Backrahmen mit den
Maßen schau ich direkt mal nach 36 x 30
cm und das ganze habe ich dann gebacken
bei 180° Ober und Unterhitze im
vorgeheizten Backofen für 22 Minuten
Minuten und so sieht mein Boden jetzt
aus den lasse ich jetzt noch vollständig
auskühlen und wir machen in der
Zwischenzeit aber weiter mit der
leckeren aber auch sehr schnellen
Buttercreme so ich mache jetzt eine
vanillebuttercreme aus quasi nur drei
Zutaten und zwar natürlich Butter die
habe ich gestern Abend schon aus dem
Kühlschrank geholt ihr könnt das
natürlich auch z D Stunden vorher aus
dem Kühlschrank nehmen damit sie richtig
schön weich ist und dann habe ich hier
noch gezuckerte Kondensmilch ihr braucht
auch keinen weiteren Zucker ich nehme
jetzt einfach dann nur noch zum
Aromatisieren Vanilleextrakt ihr könnt
aber auch Zitronenschale nehmen wenn ihr
z.B was zitroniges möchtet oder in dem
Spekulatius gewürzt ihr könnt das
Verfeinern wie Ihr möchtet jetzt fragt
euch wahrscheinlich warum habe ich h
zwei verschiedene Buttersorten es gibt
einmal süßrahmen und einmal
sauerrahmenbutter süßrahmen schmeckt
dann wirklich so sahnig süß und
sauerrahmen schmeckt dann wirklich so
ganz ganz leicht säuerlich aber dadurch
dass wir bei dieser Buttercreme sowieso
den Geschmack übertünchen mit
gezuckerter Kondensmilch und
Vanilleextrakt ist es egal für welche
Butter ihr euch entscheidet ich mach's
dann auch ganz oft so dass ich einfach
Mixe f50ft50ft oder eben nur eine
Variante nehme also das ist wirklich
kein Hexenwerk und jetzt gebe ich die
Butter einmal in meine Rührschüssel und
schlage das schon so ich würde sagen 5 6
7 Minuten schön hell cremig dann gebe
ich die gezuckerte Kondensmilch und
Vanilleextrakt dazu und lass das weitere
Z D Minuten schlagen der ganze Vorgang
dauert also so ca 10 Minuten vielleicht
auch bis zu 12 je nachdem was für eine
Maschine ihr habt es geht auch mit dem
Handrührgerät aber dann seid ihr da
wirklich 20 Minuten dran also hört auf
meine Worte nimmt euch da dafür wirklich
Zeit denn dann verändert die Butter
nicht nur das Aussehen und die
Konsistenz sondern eben auch den
[Musik]
Geschmack
so die Konsistenz hat sich enorm
verändert genauso wie ich euch das
gerade beschrieben habe also man glaubt
kaum dass das zum größten Teil aus
Butter besteht und wie gesagt ist auch
das Mundgefühl jetzt ein ganz anderes
dadurch dass ihr das eben so schön
fluffig aufgeschlagen habt so und jetzt
wird das Ganze natürlich noch eingefärbt
in grün ich habe jetzt hier meine
Lebensmittelfarbe und es gibt ja den
Trick dass wenn ihr eure
Lebensmittelfarbe erwärmt oder eben das
mit der Buttercreme zusammenrührt und
dann erwärmt dass die Farbe noch mal
intensiver wird das könnt ihr gerne
machen wenn ihr eine Farbe da habt die
nicht ganz so intensiv ist wobei ich
sagen muss wenn ihr da eigentlich
ordentlich an Farbe reingibt also ich
habe jetzt hier z.B Pistazien grün
genommen und wenn ihr wollt dass es so
ein richtig dunkles Grün wird gibt's ja
nicht nur den Trick mit dem Erwärmen
also nicht die ganze Buttercreme sondern
nur ein Teil das kann ich euch gleich
auch zeigen es gibt nämlich auch noch
den Trick da noch mal ein bisschen
schwarz mit reinzugeben aber nicht zu
viel einfach damit es ein bisschen
dunkler wird aber ich mache das jetzt
Schritt für Schritt und gucke jetzt
erstmal wie sich das Ganze verfärbt weil
wir haben eine riesen riesen Topf an
weißer Masse und da braucht man glaube
ich schon ganz schön viel von der
[Musik]
Farbe so also ihr seht ja jetzt wenn man
ein Teil der Buttercreme in die
Mikrowelle gibt wirklich nur bei 600
Watt für ein paar Sekunden es darf jetzt
nicht zu flüssig sein und dann umrührt
dann ist es auf jeden Fall jetzt ein
intensiveres grün als hier also das ist
schon sehr pastellig und das ist halt ja
ein bisschen stärker aber das reicht mir
noch nicht weil ich möchte so ein
richtiges Tannengrün und daher tue ich
jetzt noch mehr von der grünen
Lebensmittelfarbe rein und eben noch so
ein kleines bisschen schwarz und dann
sollte das eigentlich ein richtig
schönes Tannengrün
[Musik]
ergeben so Buttercreme ist fertig und
jetzt geht's einmal ans ausstechen bzw
ausschneiden unserer runden Kreise
rundenkreis doppelt gemoppelt auf jeden
Fall werde ich jetzt erstmal anfangen
mit 14 cm ich nehme jetzt hier meinen
Tortenring und mach den einfach immer
kleiner aber ihr könnt einfach auch eine
Schüssel nehmen oder einfach auch nach
Augenmaß einfach hauptsache ihr werdet
immer 2 cm kleiner also fange ich an mit
14 cm hier am Rand stech mir hier
einfach so ein Kreis ein dann kann ich
nämlich gleich einfach alle schneiden
hier steche ich den nächsten Kreis ein
so dann gehe ich auf 12 cm da auch
wieder zwei Kreise dann auf ze gucken ob
ich dann acht überhaupt noch brauche
weil wir werden ja noch Verschnitt haben
und das werden wir uns dann wie so eine
Art cakeepopmasse zusammen kneten und
dann so die Spitze quasi Formen so genau
also nur noch 10 cm und dann braucht ihr
gar nicht weiter runter gehen aber ihr
müsst euch das alles nicht merken ich
schreibe euch ja alles ganz genau unten
in die Infobox also nicht nur hier die
ganzen Details sondern auch die ganzen
[Musik]
Zutaten
so lasst euch nicht verunsichern von
dieser Optik das wird später wie ein
richtig schöner Tannenbaum aussehen und
ich habe jetzt hier oben doch noch genug
übrig gehabt um hier die Spitze noch zu
formen falls ihr euch falls ihr so ein
Verschnitt habt dass es nicht mehr geht
dann einfach nur hier die restlichen
Kuchenreste quasi mit ein bisschen
Buttercreme einfach vermengen und dann
könnt ihr selber so eine spitze Form mit
der Hand das ist noch mal so Plan B so
und jetzt nehme ich mir hier den
allerersten Boden geb das hier auf meine
Tortenplatte und dann habe ich mir
überlegt aromatisi ich das ganze hier
noch mit
Himbeermarmelade einfach damit ich noch
so ein kleinen fruchtigen Part mit drin
hab gibt das aber nur in die Mitte also
lass auf jeden Fall so ein halben
Zentimeter noch außen an Platz übrig
genau und jetzt wird einfach nur
gestapelt mit Buttercreme erstmal nur
innen und später auch außen und dann
schnitzen wir uns das quasi
zurecht
[Musik]
dadurch dass jetzt alles frisch ist ne
ich habe die Böden frisch gemacht die
Buttercreme frisch gemacht ist es ein
bisschen B instabil was gar kein Problem
ist denn Buttercreme ist sehr
pflegeleicht ihr nehmt euch einfach
schaschckspieße oder irgendetwas was ihr
da so reinstecken könnt und gebt das für
eine halbe Stunde in den Kühlschrank und
jetzt ist es auch relativ fest jetzt
nehme ich mir einfach meine mein Messer
und Schnitz mir das so ein bisschen
schon mal zurecht aber nicht zu viel
also ihr geht einfach wirklich so ein
bisschen schräg runter lasst es einfach
runterfallen das heben wir dann gleich
auf und dann kann auch schon die erste
Schicht Buttercreme einmal drauf sehr
großzügig gerne denn die zweite Schicht
wird auch schon die dekoschicht sein und
es ist wirklich kinderleicht Leute also
vorem ich finde auch jetzt sieht noch so
hässlich aus aber das Endergebnis wird
so hübsch werden dass da glaubt man gar
nicht dass hieraus gleich eine schöne
tannbaumtorte sein
[Musik]
wird
so die Torte durfte jetzt noch mal für
20 bis 30 Minuten in den Kühlschrank und
die ist jetzt richtig schön fest jetzt
können wir Sie weiter verarbeiten ich
habe mir die restliche Buttercreme in
einen Spritzbeutel gefüllt und vorne
dran ist eine offene Sterntülle ich
persönlich finde jetzt je kleiner desto
besser also das ist jetzt nicht ganz so
groß die Öffnung dadurch haben wir dann
ein richtig schönes Muster und ich habe
jetzt auch meine drehbare Tortenplatte
unten drunter weil jetzt ist es so ein
bisschen Fleißarbeit macht aber auch
Spaß muss ich sagen und zwar gehen wir
einmal mit der Tülle von unten nach oben
und dann immer so weiter bis wir eine
Umrandung haben und dann hangeln wir uns
so von Etage zu Etage bis ganz nach
oben
[Musik]
also ich bin gerade richtig froh dass
ich die Böden noch in bordeaux rot
eingefärbt habe weil ich finde das
harmoniert so gut mit der grünen Farbe
und jetzt ma ich den Tast Test für euch
wenn ihr mit der Gabel an den Boden geht
ich weiß nicht ob man es hört ob das
Mikro so gut ist aber man hört dass der
Boden halt super saftig ist und das muss
ja auch weil man hat schon ein relativ
hohen Boden und dann hat man ja noch die
Marmelade eine Zwischenschicht und die
Buttercreme man muss natürlich schon
Buttercreme Fan sein ich mag nicht jede
Art von Buttercreme aber die hier mag
ich total gerne ist einer meiner
liebsten Rezepte so jetzt probiere ich
mal für
euch sie schmeckt halt sehr vanillig
muss ich sagen und es ist auch noch mal
ein Unterschied ob die T jetzt lange
draußen steht dann ist es natürlich
relativ weich und wenn sie dann frisch
aus dem Kühlschrank kommt dann habt ihr
eine härtere Buttercreme macht finde ich
auch noch mal was mit dem Geschmack ich
finde beides sehr lecker wie gesagt
schmeckt sehr sehr vanillig sehr lecker
und ist ein richtig krasser Hinkucker
Leute also wenn ihr die nachmacht jetzt
zu den Feiertagen dann Ciao ich glaube
eure Familie wird sagen wie lange
standest du dafür in der Küche und dafür
ging es auch eigentlich echt schnell ihr
könnt mir gerne mal in die Kommentare
schreiben was ihr jetzt zu den
Feiertagen macht also wir machen so dass
wir uns einfach mit der Familie Fam
Treffen zusammen essen zusammen Zeit
verbringen und dieses Jahr ist es sogar
geplant dass wir ganz anders als in den
letzten Jahren wo wir die Zeit mit der
Familie verbracht haben dass wir
wegfliegen hams und ich aber wir haben
noch nichts gebucht also wenn ihr das
ganze nicht verpassen möchtet dann
schaut auch gerne mal bei Instagram
vorbei ich gönne mir das jetzt mal mit
noch ein Cappuccino dazu und sage bis
zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]
tschüss